And so as far as I'm concerned,
the working class needs a voice
and
it isn't obvious that they have one at
the moment.
Having said that,
however,
it isn't obvious to me at all
that the people who purport to stand for
the working class actually do so or that
if they do so,
that the reason they do so is because
they're all compassionate and
sympathetic and loving and kind and St.
like I'm more convinced by Orwell's
argument.
So back to the NDP,
the people I met at the leadership
level,
a lot of them I had a fair bit of
admiration for.
But as I worked with the party over
about a five year period,
there's this contradiction that Cape
kept emerging for me.
And that was that I didn't really like
the low level party functionary activist
types.
Like they just weren't personally
appealing to me.
They seem peevish and resentful.
And then at the same time I was going to
college,
I was about 17.
I got elected to the Senate on the
College Board of Governors.
And at that time Alberta was
conservative politically right?
It still is of course,
but they.
It was part of the progressive
conservative empire because they ruled
Alberta forever and all the board of
governor members were basically
nominees,
right?
They were conservative nominees,
so these were conservative people and I
was an NDP member and I thought when I'd
worked for small business men too,
who weren't NDP,
they were.
They were conserved.
I've never figured that out.
I'll tell you about that in a minute,
but I had a bad case of cognitive
dissonance because actually turned out
that I admired the people on the board
of governors and they were mostly.
It was in grand prairie.
It's not a very big place and it's not
very old.
And so if you were reasonably successful
in grand prairie,
the probability that you would inherited
your money from the arrest to across
aristocracy was zero because there
wasn't one.
Right.
The whole damn town was 50 years old.
So if you had any influencer or wealth,
you are a small businessman,
small to middle sized businessmen and
you'd.
You knew what you were doing.
And I actually admired these people and
I thought,
well,
that's not very good.
I mire them and I don't share their
political views.
And then there's these other people with
whom I hypothetically share political
views and I don't admire them at all.
What's going on?
And then I read road to Wigan pier and I
thought,
oh,
that's it.
They don't like the poor.
They just hate the rich.
It's not the same thing.
It's not the same set of motivations.
And so let's say that you're a
postmodernist and you privileged
compassion for the oppressed.
Think,
well,
what do you pushed to the margins?
Well,
what are you doing with all your hatred
and your resentment and your evil?
It's like you don't any of that.
That's a bad theory.
That's a really bad theory.
Okay,
so fine.
So you can say,
well yeah,
you can say that,
but I don't buy it.
I still think that the people who stand
to speak for the oppressed are in fact
motivated by empathy and sympathy.
Their hearts are in the right place.
See,
I don't really buy that either because I
don't really think generally speaking
that it's a credible claim for someone
to make that their heart is in the right
place.
Now you can ask that of yourself and if
you think your heart is in the right
place,
well more power to you.
You know,
I,
I can't see the halo from here.
However,
and so given that you're just as
malevolent as your neighbor or maybe
even more so and that that's actually
pretty malevolent given the intrinsic
nature of human beings.
I can't help but wonder what you're
doing with all those traits that you're
not admitting to,
but you can.
You could even object.
Well,
you know,
that's a pretty pessimistic view of
human kind.
It's not by the way,
it's just not naive,
but anyways,
you could object that and you can say
no.
Actually,
the weight of moral authority is in fact
on the left,
the radical left with those who identify
with the oppressed and who are working
better,
their conditions.
Okay,
fair enough.
So then let's say,
well,
let's give those people some power and
if they're actually motivated by
compassion and empathy and desire for
the working class,
if you give them power and you give the
ideas power,
then as those ideas unfold in real time,
you're going to find out better for the
working class,
let's say,
or did they get worse?
Because we could.
We could consider that like an
experiment.
We could consider the come proof.
I don't know what else you would do.
I don't know how else you would.
You would come to your decision because
it's just theory until you see it
happen.
Now.
Niches sat back in the 18,
late 18 hundreds that after he said that
God was dead.
And I suppose that would also mean the
theory that of suffering that I outlined
at the beginning that is that the basis
of Judeo Christian civilization,
the Guard was dad in the people had
killed him and that we'd never find
enough water to wash away the blood.
It's a paraphrase.
But I,
I've got the basic message,
right?
And he also said there'll be two
consequences of that nihilism because
there's no transcendent meaning and a
move to totalitarianism because people
can't tolerate nihilism.
He said the most likely pathway to
totalitarianism would communism.
Essentially.
He didn't quite use those words,
but
he meant that
he words are close enough.
He said socialism,
but I'm going to use communism to
distinguishing it,
distinguish it from Democratic
Socialism.
And he said that probably tens of tens
of millions of people would die in the
20th century as we played out that
experiment.
And then he said,
but it might be worth it if we learn
something from it.
Rough man.
I mean,
and,
and unbelievable.
Like I cannot figure out how in the
world he knew that that was going to
happen.
Especially so far in advance.
But Dostoevsky knew the same thing.
He wrote this book called the Devil's
are the possessed.
You could read that.
That's a great book.
It takes about 150 pages to get going.
But once it like everything,
everything snaps together after that.
And then it moves.
And it's basically his prophecy about.
It's an examination of the kind of
person who had arisen in the aftermath
of the death of God in Russia who would
lead the communist revolution.
That's essentially it.
It's brilliant.
It's,
it's,
it's terrifying,
and it's a great intro to soldier
Knutson's Gulag archipelago,
which describes what did happen when
those sort of people took over the
revolution.
So let's look at what happened after the
revolution and we might say,
well,
this,
how about we replicate the experiment a
few times because you know how it is.
If you're running this scientific
experiment,
you want to find out what something does
if you allow it to behave,
you don't want to just run it once
because while maybe there was something
specific about those conditions that
lead to the outcome.
You want to generalize it across
multiple circumstances.
So we might say,
well,
let's take this set of ideas and let's,
uh,
let's run it on large scale over a very
long period of time in a variety of
exceptionally diverse cultures and
languages.
So let's do that.
Okay,
well we can first start with the with
the Soviet people even now because it's
like the 100th anniversary of the
Russian revolution are celebrating
Lennon.
It's like,
that's not good.
That's like celebrating Hitler.
Okay,
I'm dead serious about that.
It's not good,
and the fact that people can dare to
think that that's okay means that
there's something wrong with the way
that we look at history.
Landon was a monster and if you want to
know about that,
you can read Solzhenitsyn's writings
about lending because they communist
apologist say,
well,
it wasn't landing.
Lennon was a good guy.
He was all motivated by love of the
working class.
It's like,
well,
his henchmen was stolen and if you're
Hansman is Stellan,
you're not a good guy.
And and London was around during the
early collectivization and if you read
what he wrote,
you'll find out he is perfectly willing
to have any number of people die as long
as his ideological system could be
brought into big.
So there's no celebrating Lennon.
There's no work,
cool young Marxists,
hip revolutionaries,
and he's our idol.
It's like there's none of that.
Not if you know anything,
not if you're decent,
whether it's death of the Kulaks I told
you about that there was the Ukrainian
famine.
That's $6 million gone there.
There was the rise of the Gulag state
because it turned out that Russia,
the Soviet Union couldn't run on the
principles that it had that had had a
laid down as sacrosanct that just didn't
work.
So you had to enslave everybody and run
your economy as a slave state
essentially.
And try not to kill the people into
gulags so fast that you can't suck some
productive labor out of them is the
death of tens of millions of people.
We don't even know.
The estimates range from 15 to $60
million and like we won't get too picky
picayune about the numbers because after
the first 10 million you kinda made your
point and the fact that we don't know
between 15 and 60 is actually an
indication of the horror of it because
our count is off by tens of millions and
that's only within the last century.
And then there was the 1956 crackdown on
Hungary and the 1968 invasion of
Czechoslovakia.
Then there was the whole like thermo
nuclear Holocaust thing that was going
on at the same time,
and the fact that in 1962 and in 1984,
we were seconds away from complete
annihilation,
right during the Cuban missile crisis,
the keys were in the intercontinental
ballistic missile release systems.
And Castro,
as he admitted to Jimmy Carter in case
any of you are Castro fans,
which you shouldn't be,
that he was perfectly willing to have
Cuba annihilated if it would've meant
the defeat of the United States.
And then in 1984 approximately,
I may have the date exactly wrong,
the Russians received an indication from
their early warning systems that the
Americans had launched five Thurman
Nuclear Missiles and one Russian decided
that it was a mistake and refused to
launch the retaliation.
And he just died about two weeks ago.